you see that i've already taken a bite i
had to i couldn't help it but you see
that it's just fluffy regular glazed
donut and that is what randy's is all
about you guys kind of keep it classic
keep it original right we do and that's
what creates that light and fluffy donut
on the inside but still taller and wider
on the outside you know it's recipes
we've had forever and it really works
the magic i love it but also on top of
that you do have the creative decorative
donuts as well let's talk about some of
those we're appealing to that crowd as
well we've got the times oreos eminems
s'mores
different breakfast cereals
nutella is a big favorite
buttercrum is crazy you know that in our
and our basics apple fritter cinnamon
roll
old fashions it all works it all works
it always we see people in line already
here but you said this has been going on
since 8 am this morning when you all
open no
5 30 5 30 since you opened this line has
been going on yeah we've had as many as
probably 60 or 70 cars in line
and no 100 people standing in line to
come in that's what it's all about
because this menu is so good and on top
of the donuts you also have breakfast
sandwiches i did not know that yeah our
ham and cheese croissants and plain
croissants are amazing we're introducing
some other breakfast sandwiches once we
get a little more stable
in a couple of months stable look at
this line you guys are settled it's done
you guys are here
i i think we are you know we've
definitely the word is out we've
definitely thrown our line into the
water with four stores
and two more coming that i can't talk
about yet we're we're here in the valley
for good
thank you so much we are it is we are so
glad so grateful that you came to our
community and i'm going to finish my
donut now come on down visit tell
everybody the address 2170 south rainbow
boulevard just north of sahara come on
down love to see you